Namsaya
Gurusayabda
Naam
Her name is UV
and she is a teacher.  There is a question from
a friend that in many different nations
and civilizations and cultures they believe in
different gods and they have different
concepts of God and different names of
gods.  So she is saying it is the case where the
names of the gods are different but they worship
actually one same God and actually they worship
different gods.
Sister ask that there are in some religion
different names of God.  So she is asking is it the
same god with different name which
religion I am talking about sister if you don't give me
the name of the religion name of the god
how can I say they are the same god
ibus
islam my friend
is a muslim asking this
question, but she is not so sure about which religion
she is referring to?
She doesn't how can I reply?
But in Islam we believe there is only one
God who is God for all the human beings.
You can call God by any name but it should be a
pure name.  As Allah says I mention my
talk in Surah Isra Chapter 17 and Number 110
Kuldullah Ab Rahman Amad Asman Husna See
You Call Upon Him By Allah and By Rahman
By Whichever Name You Call Upon Him To Him
Belongs The Most Beautiful Name So If Is The
Beautiful Name Which Allah Has
Given Matching With The Criteria We Have No
Problem As Long As The Attributes Are
Correct And The Concept Is Correct Hope The
Answer The Question After All Rabbul Alameen